government is today announcing plans to
allow people who come
into contact with someone with covert 19
to avoid isolation by taking daily tests
so let's find out
a bit more about that the foreign
secretary donald trump joins us now from
westminster and just tell us a bit more
about these plans
to allow people to take daily tests
rather than isolate what's the idea
good morning sophie well look we've made
great progress with the rollout of the
vaccine
over 34 million people have had their
first dose 60 percent of the population
and one of the things we're looking
towards are the next steps of the
roadmap so obviously the 17th of may is
a stepping stone and then
at the 21st of june and as part of the
process of easing out of
uh lockdown we want to make sure that
we're looking at it we're trialing it
and we're
obviously testing it very carefully but
whether the the
the current system of uh iso isolation
at home
can be uh if you like scale back
and the way to do that or one of the
ways to do it and again i just emphasize
we're testing it is to have these rapid
tests so that you take
a one a day and as long as you haven't
got symptoms that would allow you to
avoid having to do the isolation you'd
otherwise need to
it's just one of the tools along with
the vaccine that we're
we're looking at very closely to make
sure that we take steps out of this lock
down back to normal
in a sure footed way is there a risk
about the reliability of these rapid
tests though the lateral flow tests um
apparently they only identify around 58
of people who have covered without
symptoms is that really good enough
well that's all the more reason that
we're testing it looking at it very
carefully but you'd have to take them
daily
you would have to be without symptoms
and it's on top of all the other
measures so it's something that we're
looking at but of course as you can see
it's always a balance
we're not going to do anything that
would imperil the huge progress we've
made
in rolling out this vaccine keeping
people safe getting the economy back to
normal
you talk about the huge progress in
rolling out the vaccine the sunday times
is reporting that secondary school
pupils
could be offered the fisa vaccine as
soon as september is that something
under consideration
well i'm not going to speculate what
we're going to do beyond the existing
road map the key thing we're focused on
right now and i know there's a lot of
speculation safe in the papers but the
key thing we're focused
on right now is making sure that every
adult has the vaccine
i was offered the vaccine by the end of
july is it under consideration though
it will be a massive accomplishment but
it's also the point at which
uh and you'll have seen it from the road
map that almost all of the social
restrictions will be lifted
um but uh and i and i can't talk the
details of um
of the other trials because that's uh
not within my portfolio but you're right
that we're looking at all the different
contingencies to make sure
that the the easing up of the
restrictions the returning to normal can
be done in a safe and secure way
okay you're talking about of course the
success of the vaccine roll out and
those
next steps going forward almost 70
percent
of people in of adults in england now
have covered
antibodies either through pro-infection
or because they've been vaccinated
but we're still not even allowed to give
our mums a hug if both of us have been
fully vaccinated
why not look um there's all of the
risks that come with this that we just
got to gauge very carefully
on the 17th of may we'll take another
the third step in the roadmap if you
like
um we'll ease up there'll be more
opportunities for uh households to make
a mix inside subject to the
the caveats on that and then come the
21st of june which is
you know we're already into may uh we'll
have almost all the social restrictions
um that will be lifted so all i'd say to
people at this stage is i know that
people are hankering just uh
to go a bit faster but actually we've i
think
i feel vindicated that taking steady
steps out of the lockdown is the smart
way to go
and then we can assess all the data all
the evidence that comes back and make
sure
that we're not unpicking the gains that
have been made so we're very close now
to really turning the corner and i and i
think we we still need to be careful
as we go um because i said uh we don't
want to see the gains lost and the
sacrifices that have been made
um uh are undone i mean you talk about
balancing risk
surely it's got to be quite low risk to
hug someone who's been vaccinated
at a time when infections are so low and
of course every death is a tragedy
but there were seven deaths from covered
yesterday an estimated
450 people die of cancer every day
they're still not allowed to hug their
loved ones we're at risk of
prioritizing covert above all else right
now
well you've we've heard this debate over
the last year and we've always said it
everywhere but it's more
it's not really a debate to have over
the last year is it i accept that a time
when infection rates were very high when
deaths were high that was not the
debate to be having but right now when
there were seven covert deaths
recorded yesterday would 70 if adults in
england have antibodies
surely this is the time to be having the
debate and we are and we've had it for
the last year
and the question will be i mean the the
question you asked takes us straight
into vaccine certificates and all the
rest of that she's been very contentious
for various reasons all i'd say is
actually if you take a look at the big
picture
by the time we get to the 21st of june
almost all
social restrictions will be lifted
so there's only a little bit more time
to go but it's right to make sure we do
it in a careful way
and i think the public support that
they've supported uh the approach
by and large but i think for their great
credit um and we're at
the end really of the process if you
like we've got two more steps to
to take but i do think given the the
role out of the vaccine that's exciting
it's got people thinking about
not just the social interaction but yeah
of course things like hugging you your
loved ones that you haven't been able to
do for a while but i do think we just
need to make sure that in the last lap
if you like that we're careful
and we don't lose the gains that we've
made you talk about almost all
restrictions
being lifted in the months ahead what
what exactly do you mean by that what
restrictions are going to be here today
well if you look at the roadmap it's set
up very clearly we get may the 17th
there's going to be
subject to the evidence and and the way
we set out is no earlier than the 17th
of may we'll look again at the
travel restrictions so that's something
that's going to be set out
well before then there'll be the
opportunity for households to households
to mix
um uh indoors then when we get to june
uh there's a whole range of other
lifting of restrictions and and the
roadmap sets out that that
most if not all of the social
restrictions will at that point again
subject to the evidence be lifted
so the point i'm making is and of course
we'll we'll we'll set out what other
um uh conditions and caveats and
safeguards
still need to be uh in place based on
the evidence as we go
but the point i'm i'm making is actually
that 21st of june
uh fourth step out of lockdown is is not
far away now so
i think if we just hang on keep being
guided by the science and the evidence
measure the progress we're making
carefully we're nearly there
we've seen some pretty harrowing scenes
from india a country which really is
still grappling
with their kovid 19 pandemic is the uk
doing enough to help
yes and i spoke to recently spoke to
foreign minister jaishankar
my opposite number there we've said that
we'll do whatever
we we can and whatever they ask for i do
think it's important with these
emergency uh packages you listen very
carefully to the
the indian authorities and see that
we're giving them what they they need
and want so we've given them oxygen
concentrators we've given them
ventilators we're going to be sending
out another package of thousand
ventilators
um very shortly we've also looked at
these
oxygen generators like mini factories
and that's the thing they need right now
um and i've been in regular contact with
foreign minister jai shankar i'll be
seeing him
uh tomorrow as well and we're doing
everything that our indian friends need
in their hour of need i just want to
move on to
talk about the funding of boris
johnson's
flat renovation a story that of course
has been bubbling
for a little while now and the sunday
times has been told that there was a
second
invoice for the work that was paid
directly
settled directly with a supply by a
third party believed to be a donor
is that true well sophie as the
prime minister set out this week he
covered the cost himself
um he's followed all the relevant codes
of conduct
at all relevant times he took official
advice all along the way there are
there are three reviews now i think uh
uh into this and i think the right thing
for me to do is not add
political commentary that could
otherwise prejudice those um reviews but
to respect the integrity of them so i'm
not going to offer you unafraid
any more commentary or or if you like
chatter on the various different reports
and speculation that i've seen in the
sunday papers
i'm not asking you for commentary or
about speculation i'm just asking for
clear answers
to questions yes and i think the prime
minister's been very clear
and we've got for any questions that
regarded as uh
not yet answered there are three reviews
uh the prime minister's
set up some of them is engaging fully
with all of them and i think the right
thing to do is to respect
the integrity of them let them run their
course and they'll resolve any
outstanding questions people have
oh right the premise has been very clear
i must have missed this
because i believe the key question is
who initially paid for the refurbishment
of the flat so has it been clear in
answering that i think as i said i can
go back over what i said to you before
um sophie but the pm's been very clear
covered the cost himself
he's followed all the codes of conduct
he's taken official advice
um and frankly i i don't know the uh any
of the other details of it and there are
three reviews that will
uh look into those questions and the
prime minister and the government of
course and
uh embraced the transparency and the
integrity of those processes
okay you're talking about the
transparency and the integrity of the
processes
uh the reviews that are going on and one
of them is being carried out by
christopher guy the new
advisor on ministerial standards so who
has the power to decide
whether the conclusions of that
investigation are published and acted on
well we've i think the prime minister
has been clear that we will uh have full
transparency in relation to the
processes
um and not quite the question i asked
though is it well
so look that process is something that's
been in place
um for successive governments uh he's
going to engage fully with it
and there'll be transparency uh around
the conclusions
what's the answer then if you're being
clear and transparent what's the answer
to the question
so this i thought i'd answered it what's
the specific question you think i've
overlooked
sophie who has the power to decide
whether the conclusions of the
investigation being carried out by
christopher
the guide are published and acted on
well in terms of um the publication that
the prime minister's already been
cleared that the
the there's going to be full
transparency if you're asking
uh who has the uh ultimate
accountability over the prime minister
it's the
electorate and the voters um that's the
way it works
thanks so much for explaining how you
know the electoral system works in the
uk i really appreciate that
i'm just asking who has the power to
decide whether the conclusions of that
investigation are acted on the answer is
the prime minister isn't it
well the prime minister is the ultimate
arbiter of
uh or the ultimate accountability for
the ministerial
code uh he has the authority to dismiss
ministers to make sure they live up to
the code
and so if your question is then but who
holds him to account ultimately and
that's why i come back to the point i
made earlier there's no
separate uh body or individual that will
have power over him
is the british people he's accountable
to them that's why we have elections
but when it comes to this investigation
yeah the prime minister is effectively
judge jury and executioner for his own
trial no because he's uh
as i said he's going to be fully
transparent about it he'll be
accountable to parliament
uh which is of course the main way the
government the day is held to account
and then ultimately the ballot box is
the way it works
okay um let's just try and ask about
another claim that's in the sunday times
i've got a feeling i know what the
answer to this one's going to be as well
and but the sunday times
has also been told that the prime
minister asked a conservative party
donor to pay for his child care costs is
that true
i've got no idea you think i have
conversations like that with the prime
minister um
i i can't comment on every uh little bit
of gossip that's in the newspapers
sophie
i've had a pretty full schedule this
week and next week with the g7
i've been out at the un cyprus talks
i've been talking to the un secretary
general so forgive me if i don't
know all the ins and outs of the prime
minister's private life and i wouldn't
comment on them even if i did
it's not the prime minister's private
life though is it it's not just gossip
the electoral commission is
investigating whether the law has been
broken
exactly so uh and and i think the right
gossip is that i think it
i think well the last thing you uh asked
me about i think is uh
an example of tittle tattle but look i'm
not doubting that there are important
issues at stake which is why the
electoral commission review should be
allowed to run its course and i don't
think the right thing for me to do
is say anything that could prejudice or
is political commentary on that
is 157 000 pounds a year a decent salary
yes of course it is and uh if you're
referring to i mean that
is referring to what um cabinet members
of the prime minister and of course we
know when we
when we go into public service um
we do it as a matter of honour um and uh
it's a great privilege to be able to do
these roles with these jobs in
government
and of course sophie you'll know that
we've been freezing ministerial salaries
for many years now we've taken that
decision
because of the financial climate that
we're in and we do these jobs because
we're committed to public service
you're talking about the important
issues that you've been involved in of
course we know that there are so many
important issues
going on at the minute with a pandemic
and elsewhere if that is the case
why is the prime minister spending his
time phoning newspaper editors to
criticize dominic cummings
no again you're asking me to comment or
verify the speculation in the
in the newspapers but um the the prime
minister is
i i know because i saw him uh last week
absolutely focused on the job
of getting us through the pandemic and
wants to get back to the leveling up
agenda making sure all parts of the uk
are prospering and we've got the
investment we need and we've got this
exciting year of global leadership with
the g7 presidency and the foreign
ministers who i'll be welcoming to
london next week so
we're looking at all of those issues and
that's where the prime minister is
focusing his time his efforts and his
energy
so this is genuinely what i don't
understand about this
is that with all the things that you're
listening there that the government
needs to try
and focus on all the things that are
important issues for the electorate
and the government as well why don't you
just shut this story down
why do you have all these investigations
why is the cabinet secretary spending
his time
trying to work out what happened um you
know when you could just
answer the questions who paid for the
original loan i
just don't understand why you're just
not forthcoming with the answers i think
i think the prime minister's been
crystal clear about it i can repeat the
answers that i've given to you
but i do think if you've got those
reviews underway the right things you
set them up
in order to answer precisely the
questions sophie you're asking me i
think it's right thing to do to let them
run their course
and not to try and prejudice them with
political commentary it's fine for the
journalists to do it
in the papers but i don't think it's
right for a cabinet member to do that
do you really think the prime minister's
been crystal clear yeah i do and i think
you know i've been out campaigning the
local elections as well as all the stuff
i'm doing as foreign secretary
generally no one has asked me about this
okay
um fine well let's move on let's move on
you're hosting an
in-person meeting of foreign ministers
this week and you're going to be talking
about
improving girls education you're going
to be talking about reducing poverty
incredibly important things of course
but you're also cutting the uk's aid
spending by 4
billion pounds so are you just replacing
hard cash with one words here
no i don't think so look you're right to
say we've had to take this extremely
difficult decision to reduce
and find savings in the aid budget and
that's because of the impact that covert
has had the biggest
contraction we've seen the economy in
300 years of budget deficit
uh double what we saw at the peak of the
financial crisis in 2008 nine
but let's face it we're still let's be
honest about it be clear about it we're
still getting
10 billion pounds of aid uh
this year we're the largest contributor
to gavi
uh the global vaccine alliance with the
third biggest
uh g7 aid donor measured as a proportion
of gdp
on everything from climate finance where
we're doubling our contribution to girls
education
where we're leading this charge to get
40 million more girls 12 years of
quality education
we have an enormous impact um and we as
i said we're still not withstanding the
savings i've been
very honest and transparent about we're
still one of the the leading
aid spenders in the world but one thing
we're also doing and that's why
we're proud to host the g7 presidency is
we're using uh
the example we set the leadership we
provide and our convening power to get
other countries
uh to to step up in what is a team
effort whether it's the the challenge of
shifting the dial on climate change or
girls education
or indeed getting the very poorest
countries access to the vaccine and
that's what global britain's all about
being a force for good in the world
i understand of course the financial
pressures that every government has to
grapple with but can you guarantee that
these cuts to aid
have been made to make try and make sure
that they
minimize the harm on the poorest people
so first of all i don't think people do
really realize certainly some of the
commentary doesn't doesn't take full
count of just how much damage the
uh covert has done to the public
finances and that's why i gave
the figures i did earlier but the way
we've approached this first of all as i
said we've got 10 billion pounds
huge amount still what the third biggest
g7 donor and what i did at the start of
the process is set seven
priorities from uh climate finance and
climate change
through to humanitarian um uh uh
support and relief and made sure rather
than salami slicing budgets according to
i didn't know
10 15 whatever percent we actually said
no we're going to really focus on
driving
and getting the very most out of the 10
billion pounds that taxpayers in the
public funding
is going into and the reason we wanted
to do that is to have a more strategic
approach and also to get maximum value
out of every penny of taxpayers money
that goes abroad and that's the approach
we've taken talk about maximum value
out of taxpayers money the u.n
population fund which supports
family planning so the uk is cutting 85
of its support this year unicef says
it's seeing a 60
drop in core funding and they say the
cuts are falling
on the shoulders of the world's children
are you comfortable with that look i i
found the
the process of making those savings very
difficult but of course
that you'd expect that what i'd say in
relation to
public health is we're still putting in
uh 1.3 billion pounds
into global public health initiatives
next year over five years we're putting
1.6
billion into gavi the global vaccine
alliance obviously our public health
spending has been shifted
and focused on the pandemic and on
everything from the billion doses that
we've secured
for the poorest countries around the
world to the fact that we invested in
the r
d that produced the astrazeneca vaccine
which is now
uh helping so many countries come
through the pandemic i think we've had
an incredible impact
and i i can tell you when i speak to dr
ted ross at the world
health organization or the un secretary
general i spoke to both of them in
person this week
uh they've got nothing but praise for
the huge impact and the leadership that
we're taking
the g7 this week the foreign minister's
meeting is a great opportunity not just
to lead by example
but to use our convening power and make
it a real team effort
to tackle these problems together okay
dominic rob thank you very much for
coming on the program this morning thank
you